they have welcomed me with such open
arms at a time when i was feeling
particularly down and broken
lori lachlan opens up in her first tv
appearance since the college admission
scandal
over a year and a half after completing
her prison sentence the actress breaks
her silence
all good you want me to leave it right
there lori appears in project angel
food's lead with love telethon sharing
details about her volunteer work
i've been working with project angel
food for a year and a half now and it's
been one of the most rewarding
experiences of my life my favorite is
doing the deliveries i have the same
delivery route once a week and i see the
same people and it's so nice to make
that connection with those people
and in a rare comment about life post
scandal lori reflects on one of her low
points
they have welcomed me with such open
arms at a time when i was feeling
particularly down and broken
that's how i found a home here
and
that's what i feel like they did for me
and
that's why i'm so proud to be here and
working with this organization because
they really do care
the appearance follows a chaotic era for
lori she was a key figure in the college
admission scandal which kicked off with
her and her husband massimo gianouli's
arrest in 2019.
the couple was accused of paying 500
dollars in bribes with the money
ensuring their daughters isabella rose
and olivia jade would be accepted into
usc
in 2020 they both pled guilty to charges
related to the scandal with lori
spending two months in jail as part of
her sentence
but fast forward to 2022 the full house
star's life is looking a little more
normal
i could try she's already made her
acting return on win hope calls
and last month lori caught everyone off
guard with a surprise red carpet
appearance
lori was so low in all smiles while
supporting holly robinson pete's holly
rod foundation
i just wanted to come out and show my
love and support for holly and also the
foundation does amazing work meanwhile
it seems like one of lori's biggest
priorities right now is just being a mom
i'm like a proud mama what she's doing
with fun cameos and olivia's tick tocks
i'm a jerk you ain't never lie but hey
do me a favor call me jerk one more time
[Music]
as olivia told us last year lori was an
amazing cheerleader during her journey
on dancing with the stars
she's watching every single time she's
texting all her friends to vote she is
both of them i mean my dad too they
watch every single monday they're so
supportive
[Music]